Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman show.
I am not David Pakman. And while you may
think that I am an out of work Jim Gaffigan
stunt double, I am indeed. Jesse Dallimore,
host of the Dallimore Daily on YouTube. This past
Friday, a the brutal beating tape of Terry Nichols
was released. The brutal beating that took place
at the hands of the Memphis Police Department. An
elite group of police officers, the most highly
trained on their staff, took part in the beating
that ultimately led to his death. I'm not going
to play the footage here. It is out there. It is
public. You can find it on Twitter anywhere. You
just do a Google search and you'll find it. But I
want to talk a little bit about what was released
and the timing of the release on a Friday night.
That seemed strange to me. And then we're going
to talk about some ghoulish takes from the right,
notably Fox News and Jesse Waters. First, though,
if you haven't seen it, it is gruesome and and.
The lack of humanity that was displayed will
rock you if you are not careful about how much
you consume of it. Disgusting. Just a complete
disregard for the life and well-being of Tyree
Nichols. It also goes because they were in
the Scorpion unit, which is now apparently
been disbanded, but they were members of an elite
police unit and it was like the Keystone cops.
They were pepper spraying one another. They were
injuring themselves while trying to administer a
brutal beating on this civilian. On the citizen.
On this uncharged, not convicted unarmed
individual. It was gross, to say the least.
And what you would expect from Fox News didn't
quite come to fruition. I was actually a little
shocked at some of the more reasonable takes than
you would expect. It didn't just devolve into just
comply and this will happen. Here's Jesse WATTERS.
While still sucking up to police and showing
deference for police departments, no matter
what the charges against them are. He still seems
a little bothered by the footage. Watch this.
One mother lost four children, four
sons to homicide before the age of 30.
And so it has to stop. And these officers,
black officers in a in a black neighborhood,
they're working on a crime task force. And they
had really, really made a lot of arrests from
when this task force was put up and running
in October and had really cleaned up the
streets for now to watch this. It's just hard
to see. And I think we have another tape again,
it's about 2 minutes. We were warning another body
cam. This is graphic. Watch. He's almost there.
He's almost there. They were working on a crime
task force and they had made a lot of arrests
and had to really they had really cleaned up the
streets. But to watch this, it's hard to see, he
says. But he doesn't quite get there. He doesn't
quite ask the right questions of did they effect
the arrests they effected because of the fact that
use they use brutality and illegal means to do so.
Are they not going to question that
these cops don't feel constrained
by the Constitution to which they
swore an oath to support and defend?
Jesse WATTERS went on to have Heather McDonald
on who is protect the cops at all cost,
besmirch the prospect of diversity training within
police departments of implicit bias training. And
of course, they go to her, the expert, quote
unquote. And this is how that devolved. And
then we're going to talk about exactly how she's
wrong with some facts, with some data, with some
research. Let's bring in the author of War on
Cops. We have Heather McDonald here. Heather,
take us out. Big picture statistically,
I mean, this is this is extremely rare.
Speaker 2: Well, absolutely. And you know, Jesse,
this looks like absolutely terrible tactics.
Cops are desperate for more tactical training in
de-escalation and stress control. So they're not
put in an inner position that they feel they need
to use lethal force. And instead they're being
given implicit bias training, diversity training,
complete waste of money. But the narrative that
is being put on what looks to be a very horrific
incident is inflammatory. It's coming from the
president on down that we are living through an
epidemic of racially biased police killings of
black men. That is completely false. President
Biden just said, oh, the criminal justice system
denies equal treatment to blacks. He should know
better. Study after study coming out of Harvard,
out of Michigan State University, out of the
left wing Center for Policing Equity shows that
there is no bias in fatal police shootings.
Speaker 1: So Jesse WATTERS proclaims this is
extremely rare. I think we all know any of
us who are paying attention for any amount
of time relative to the treatment of police,
the civilians by police in the United States,
especially related to the treatment of unarmed
black men, is that this isn't an exceedingly
rare or extremely rare as he categorized it. It's
an all too common occurrence. And McDonald saying
that she blames diversity training and implicit
bias training. But we need more use of force
training. That's what we need for police. And then
she makes the bold claim that there was no racial
bias. There is no racial bias in police in fatal
police shootings. And this just flies in the face
of what we know. I'm going to read a
little bit from this Guardian article,
just one paragraph here, The Guardian article
entitled If you want to read the entire Thing,
it Never Stops. Killings by US Police reached
record high in 2022. Law enforcement killed at
least 1176 people or about 100 people a month last
year, making it the deadliest for police violence.
And this is the paragraph. Black people were 24%
of those killed last year while making up over
only 13% of the population. From 2013 to 2022,
Black residents were three times more likely to
be killed by U.S. police than white people. The
inequality is particularly severe in some cities,
including Minneapolis, where police kill
black residents at a rate 28 times higher
than white residents. And Chicago,
where the rate was 25 times higher.
And that comes from mapping police violence.
Those statistics that I just read you. So this
this claim, this bold Fox News talking point is
nothing but nonsense and lies and subterfuge.
It is playing cute with actual crime statistics
and statistics related to police brutality.
Mapping police violence also has this chart.
There is a racial disparity even in who the police
killed while they're running away. Not the police.
The the the suspect. One in every three people
killed by police was running away. Driving away or
otherwise trying to flee. Black and brown people
were more likely to be killed while fleeing.
So the nonsense that Fox News will try to
to perpetrate upon the American people,
even in the wake of a brutal gang style slaying of
a citizen, is remarkable. Republicans are rah rah,
rah rah on waving their constitutions. They're
rah rah rah rah about anti establishment and the
deep state and being scared of the government.
But when it comes to armed agents of the state
who brutally use the power, they've been
granted their arrest power, the power to
take the lives of citizens. It's crickets from
the peanut Gallery of Conservative that the
hierarchy of conservative media, they protect
the cops law and order, they say, while calling
into question the integrity of government
everywhere else. It doesn't make any sense.